[Music]
dad's not here how is he doing and what
do you think he would want to say
tonight
he's doing really well he's like you
know he's seen it probably a thousand
times
it's very emotional for him to watch
that yeah i like to watch it
and you know we wish he could be here
but you know he's here in spirit i was
recently diagnosed with throat cancer
i'm still recovering and it is difficult
to talk and to be understood
the 61 year old cancer survivor is seen
through all stages of his life in the
film
yes with a breathing tube but also as
the sexy leading man
wild and free but the most
heartwarming thing about the doc that
streams friday on amazon prime video
26 year old jack steps in for his dad
and provides the narration
i've wanted to tell a story about acting
for a very long time
and i am blessed how did your dad react
when he heard it
yeah he he loves it there's a scene in
the movie where he he comes to the
studio and i'm in there and we
we embrace and it was sort of a surprise
for him and it's something that
you know he it really means a lot to him
val's home movies also capture unguarded
moments with
several other big hollywood names here
we are
filming ourselves is that a video
rolling yeah oh that's really cool
though
did you guys get in touch with these
people like did tom cruise and kevin
bacon know they're gonna be in this yeah
yeah
my dad's like you know friends of them
he's just so
proud of this and that people get to see
a side of him that's never been seen
[Music]
before